good morning everybody it is butt-fuck
early but I'm super excited because
we're going to one of my favorite places
on earth now I haven't done a travel
video really for this place so that's
why I decided to go back to my homeland
my Anna my comic who gurukul I it's not
a word we're going to Hawaii [ __ ]
6:25 a.m. we left at like around 5:30 we
had probably one of the funniest goober
drivers ever this [ __ ] had the
thickest Chinese accent he take yes what
we were going what you guys going I said
Hawaii goes I hate you over here at
Delta Delta thank you for taking my
money and helping this fly out to Hawaii
very interesting morning everybody's
angry
Paul huge easy in my toes this my name
is Vanessa and my face looks like that
got a couple of workers young again some
customers and there the customer yelling
at a worker so it's safe to get the [ __ ]
out the city
[Music]
yeah you smelled it though right yeah
there's like fire but like you know when
you push proof in I can smell it that's
what it smelled like that's like you
were farting oh I wish I was sorry we've
landed in Hawaii we are here six hour
flight
pretty exhausted tired as [ __ ] but it
was cool because I had this little piece
of [ __ ] next to me throughout the whole
flight pissing me off
she has a boyfriend welcome to my humble
abode aka the Airbnb that were running
out when I come to Hawaii usually I like
to get an Airbnb because it's cheaper
and on top of that you have a lot more
space to roam around and if you have
friends yeah a family you can all be in
one place and then [ __ ] do dirty [ __ ]
to them without them knowing but of
course they're gonna find out it's me
because I'm doing this video another way
that I like to work on one of my basic
requirements when I get an air bimba is
that it has to have a [ __ ]
jungle gym because this is how I get my
exercise on you don't pain I hope this
thing got a good weight limit oh this is
kind of rusty dude I call these the
seesaw [ __ ] Me's basically what you do
with this is that you I don't trust this
[ __ ] rock climbing is all about having a
strong core and knowing what you do I
don't think this is gonna hold my weight
no it's cracking on your spare time you
want to go ahead and get on the slide
because slides are
[Music]
welcome my friends we are here at the
famous Zippy's I always order the same
thing as Zippy's every time that I come
here and that's usually going to be the
loco moco
we usually get like the zip pack or we
get Simon or that Portuguese bean soup
those are my personal favorites this is
all like stick-to-your-ribs food I call
this kind of like Hawaiian dennings but
not Denny's because Denny's kind of
sucks asked not unless you guys want to
sponsor me I [ __ ] love you but I
think that I'm gonna stick with my loco
moco and then I'm just gonna order a
bunch of stuff for the table and then
we're going to go through it talk about
it how I feel about it a Y gives me a
raging boner this my friends if you've
never had this before you're missing the
[ __ ] out this is a loco moco now you
have a couple of options when you get it
and get a chile moco which they have
their version of Chile that you eat with
it or you can get brown gravy now I just
would like to do both so I mix both
together so watch this [ __ ] Chile and
gravy with two sunny-side up eggs and
white rice what you're going to do is
you're going to take your fork you're
gonna pop this [ __ ] and it comes out
like a guava one of my favorite dishes
of all time and of course beneath that
you have yourself a delicious hamburger
steak and that right there my friends is
the perfect bite
salty savory that creamy yolk now if
you're unsure about what to get here as
if these I suggest that you get the zip
pack because the zip pack has a little
bit of everything we're talking terry
beef we're talking about a square of
spam fried chicken fried fish and also
some slaw on the side food a cockatrice
daikon radish and a little bit of sauce
get myself a knife dip right here
nothing stop nothing wrong with a little
bit of spam that's what's up Terry beef
sweet and salty always a perfect
combination and of course a bite of some
fried chicken fried chicken - gotta be
blessed with a little bit of Tabasco I'm
saying
that's frickin good we are at Magic
Island this is just a small little local
little beach spot that it was really
close to us and like I said it ain't
Hawaii until I touched the water with my
body and my nipples cuz I mean that [ __ ]
to be erect
we got a tarp to lay down on the floors
because I ain't trying to burn my
sensitive ass you
alright this isn't working this is the
moment that I've been waiting for let me
show you what years and years of
physical activity weight training and
sports activity does for you I'm just
gonna put this out there right now I'm
not saying LeBron James
I'm not saying Olympic athlete I'm also
not saying that I'm way better looking
than Bart but what I am saying is this
the sunscreen minute stick see that
right there that's a pectoralis morales
muscle there's a mexican muscle cousin
[ __ ] that [ __ ] did you let's hit this
water
y'all have a dip your body of hawaiian
water yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] didn't
hurt y'all dick yourselves in the water
make sure that you bless it real quick
like you being baptized don't be a
little [ __ ] I just put my foot just got
you know the good thing about Hawaiian
water since I was very warm compared to
the waters we have out in LA now I know
that you're a bit surprised and I
probably look something like a beaching
whale or a breaching whale but one thing
I did notice about people in Hawaii are
when they come here they're not so body
conscious and you can see people out
here they're either my size or bigger
and everybody should listen having fun I
feel like in LA people had this thing
where they're so self-conscious about
what they look like and they come to a
beach and I see this all the time I go
to a beach and they hit the water with
their shirts on let me tell you
something I'm a fat person you're a fat
person and just because your shirts on
you're not fooling anybody everybody
still knows that we're fat it's okay
love yourself or change it if you like
but when you come to the beach take off
that shirt get your ass in the water and
get blessed by the ocean because I love
it and if you think that you're chunky
and you feel heavy well that's what the
saltwater sore helps you float like a
baby otter
part of the excitement and even the fun
of traveling to even the place that
you've already been to before is trying
out new things and I'm all about new
experiences no matter how uncomfortable
it makes me now I'm over here with yoga
floats it's a company that does yoga on
paddle boards now this silver here
incorporates a few things that I hate in
life exercise paddle boards and yoga so
what is your the floats exactly is a
company that provides stand-up paddle
yoga so we do yoga understand a paddle
boards people usually my size come here
and do this not a lot of people my size
but let's start with the basics I've
never look at me I've never done yoga
because how I picture a guy I just
picture like this guy with a long beard
who has never rinsed his body once in
his life and he just doesn't long that's
what I'm saying so I don't know what it
is there just to put it in perspective I
think I am the youngest one here and I
think that by age I already have an
advantage and I'm not saying we'll [ __ ]
these old people up
I'm a [ __ ] soul people Oh The
Apprentice has become a master in a
matter of seconds and just to show you
my level of confidence there's a reason
why I still have my tank top and my hat
on because my body will not touch this
water
I'm audible
by the wind pickups on me
[Music]
it's not thank you so much a lot of
people might think this slot is here and
they actually think it is black because
for me prior to doing this almost off
looking at the distance and people who
are doing this now it's like
but I just ate [ __ ] in my face hurts
guys do want to try doing yoga floats or
yoga paddleboarding I suggest that you
pick this company up the instructor is
absolutely fantastic
she has walked me through it she let me
know that it's okay to follow your face
every now and then it's okay to talk big
and if you've done this before and then
fall flat on your face in front of the
whole class people my self-esteem is
pretty low right now
[Music]
[Music]